[Музика]
для всіх настав час англійської, мене
звати Мартін, і сьогодні ми збираємося
відточити вашу майстерність писати листи,
безперечно, сьогодні ви навчитеся
писати офіційними літерами, і цей урок
буде особливо корисним для  ті з
вас, що збираєтеся робити і говорити без завдання, почніть з того,
щоб відповісти на питання, чи
пишете ви листи або електронні листи своїм друзям,
які живуть далеко від вас, якщо ваша
відповідь «так», продовжуйте і дайте відповідь на це
запитання, якщо ваша відповідь тепер
це питання, на яке ви їм відповісте, уявіть
собі ситуацію, що ви отримали листа
від своєї подруги Бет, прочитав це,
але
насправді я не думаю, щоб ревнувати
через Барселону або
співчувати Бет через її
подругу, але давайте відкинемо
емоції  і зосередимося на самому листі,
і спершу давайте проаналізуємо його мету та
стиль, отримаємо перше запитання, чому Бет
пише тому, яка причина, щоб першою
розповісти про свою поїздку, а інша
поскаржитися на її фри  і дізнайтеся, яка
мета кожного абзацу, давайте зробимо це
разом перший абзац, привіт, М, тобто
привітати другий абзац, це
ввічливо почати та пояснити причину, щоб
написати, як усе йде,
сподіваюся, що все добре, третій, тобто
розповісти  про поїздку поруч поскаржитися
на супутника, добре запитати
про переваги та поради друзів по переписці
та вказати причину закінчення
листа, щоб це було метою кожного
абзацу та третього запитання, які
приклади неформальної мови ви можете
знайти насправді  це був лист до
друга правильно, тому
стиль листа неформальний
звідки ми це знаємо, давайте подивимося,
перш за все, правильний початок і
кінець привіт, м і любов Бет Бет - це
коротке ім'я, які ще скорочення
ви  wasn't I've I'm gate і
запитання та вигуки, щоб показати,
що ваш лист у неформальному стилі,
використовуйте правильні скорочення початку та закінчення,
а також запитання та
вигуки, але не так багато r  А тепер
давайте оцінимо цю букву з
точки зору екзаменатора, і спочатку ми
звернемо увагу на діапазон
лексики. Подивіться на фрази, виділені
червоним кольором, щоб отримати вищу оцінку, ви повинні
використовувати словниковий запас вищих рівнів b1 або
b2, давайте перевіримо  перша фраза -
мій друг, ви можете сказати або мій
друг, або мій друг, але майте на
увазі, що мій це рівень a1, а
мій a, щоб краще написати,
інша зрозуміла, що я можу використовувати тут
ненавиджу літаки, але ненавиджу це  дворівневий
і постійний b1 отримати що ще буде
для дива у значенні walk walk a
1-1 to be to get
виявилося також, замість цього
було неможливо було отримати ще одну
фразу не тільки, але й  фраза
з рівня b2y, щоб зробити це ще
раз, існують різні рівні
мови, якщо ви хочете отримати вищий бал
для свого письма, ви повинні використовувати
слова з вищих рівнів отримати що
ще оцінюється crema давайте звернемо
увагу на граматичні конструкції
і порахувати whi  ch використовуються так що використовується
теперішній безперервний haven't hurt present
perfect go past simple I want you were
conditional to make me disappointed
infinitive next had expected past
perfect sleeping giant does present
simple had дві моделі насправді дев'ять
різних граматичних конструкцій що
ще слід додати  можливо,
знову є пасивний пасив, ви повинні показати, що ви
володієте та можете правильно використовувати різні
граматичні конструкції, пам’ятайте про це,
напишіть свою власну літеру get, а тепер
давайте перетворимо лист, який ми читаємо, на
екзаменаційне завдання, оскільки я знаю, що екзаменаційні завдання
виглядають так і  це те, що
ви отримуєте на початку іспиту, воно
складається з контекстної ситуації,
завдання, що робити, і трьох умов,
що ви повинні зробити, коли ви його отримаєте,
давайте розберемося крок за кроком, і в цій
ситуації ви точно знатимете, з чого
почати  і що робити, щоб вони були готові до
цього, перш за все, проаналізуйте
перший абзац і підкресліть ключові
слова в нашому випадку контекст я  Останній
лист Джонні про останню подорож, і
ваш друг по переписці скаржиться на
комплект супутника, і із
завдання ми бачимо, що ви повинні написати
листа другу по переписці, який стиль
буде неформальним, звичайно,
зараз варто подумати про  синоніми
до слів, які ви підкреслили, тому замість
Джонні ми можемо використати слова trip О
- добре, на цьому етапі аналізу візьміть
ручку і запишіть на полях
синоніми, а також вони
знадобляться вам пізніше під час написання листа
правильно добре  попутник, давайте
перефразуємо це іншими словами, це ваш
партнер. О, друже, знову напишіть ці
слова на полях, і якщо ваш друг
скаржиться, на
що ви маєте написати, мені шкода чути
це право, скажіть, що ми проаналізували
лише перший абзац і  ми вже маємо
кілька ідей, які можна використати під час написання
листа, давайте перейдемо до умов
, є три умови, і кожну з
них слід проаналізувати так само,
давайте уважно розглянемо першу.  з багатьох
частин, чи складається він з
одного, двох трьох, скільки я бачу, і
це означає, що ось дві частини:
перша – де, а друга –
хто отримає те, що ще я тут підкреслив,
що останній раз просто не забути використати
правильну граматику символу минулого продовжується
або може бути минулим досконалим, добре,
давайте подумаємо, як відповісти на нього,
куди ви подорожували минулого разу.
продемонструйте свої знання словникового запасу
не так багато,
давайте знайдемо правильні фрази, як-от я поїхав у
тур по чотирма країнами по Європі чи я здійснив європейський тур у
чотири країни
чи це звучить краще набагато краще отримати та
говорити про те, кого ви можете використовувати,
просто мій друг
перша умова складається з
двох частин ми і хто граматику
слід використовувати тут минулих часів і перевірте
деякі ідеї, вам буде легше
використовувати їх під час написання справи, у вас
буде щось у вашій записці  ry або краще
на полях до часу, щоб перейти
до другої умови я, зі скількох частин
він складається, право ви можете побачити, і
набір з двох частин,
що я настійно рекомендую вам робити, це
щоразу виконувати завдання пошуку Anoeta
умова зі словом чому і
обведіть його, тому що це досить коротке слово
і іноді ви його взагалі не помічаєте
і забуваєте вказати причини, краще
обведіть і щоб запобігти вашим причинам правильні
добре і зверніть увагу на цю ідею
який супутник  чи йдеться про зовнішність
чи характер про зовнішність ми задали
питання, як він виглядає, правильно в
нашому випадку це була б людина, це
про особистісні характеристики чи
особливості, давайте подумаємо про можливі
відповіді, з яким
супутником ви б хотіли подорожувати
для мене оптимістами є ті, хто дивиться
на сонячну сторону, отримують і відповідають на
питання, чому ви будете використовувати деякі
сполучники, тому що або як
правильне встановити, аналізуючи другу умову,
ми бачимо, що  t він складається з двох частин,
ми повинні дати деяку особисту
характеристику з поясненням щоразу,
пам’ятайте, чому готовий отримати, і третя
умова, давайте подивимося на це, на
чому ми маємо зосередитися в
першу чергу, розглянемо це,
якщо вони дадуть одну пораду  або
кілька принаймні дві я бачу у множині це
означає принаймні дві поради, і
це моя ще одна пропозиція щоразу
в завданні переглядайте їхні
умови та з'ясуйте те, що має
множину, і знову або підкресліть, як О,
обведіть це, щоб винести  це на увазі,
давайте подумаємо, як це перефразувати та
можливі відповіді, якщо це дає пораду,
ми можемо використовувати фрази, які ви стріляєте, я б
рекомендував, щоб було б гарною ідеєю уникати
, іншими словами, без замість
конфліктів ми можемо використовувати проблеми зіткнення
розбіжності, але які можуть бути ваші
поради, як уникнути конфліктів,
мої планують заздалегідь я маю на увазі
домовитися до поїздки, а
інший - шукати компроміс, бути готовим до
переговорів і що  є ключем до
успішної та щасливої подорожі, які у ва
ідеї, тож давайте підсумуємо, як во
и знають, що письмові завдання виглядають пр
вильно чорними та білими лініями, і як тільки ви
итратите близько 15 хвилин на аналіз, ви
тримаєте цю картинку з пі
кресленими словами  синоніми деякі
ідеї,
як відповісти, сказано, маючи цей, чи
ви відчуваєте, що готові почати
писати, безсумнівно, це дуже хороша ідея,
перш ніж писати завдання, витратити час на
його аналіз, і тоді це взагалі не буде
проблемою
отримати те, що  чи потрібно робити після аналізу завдання,
давайте зосередимося на контурі
вашого листа, щоб абзаци,
перший з яких вітався, вітали правильно
для неформального використання літер dia пам’ятати
про кому або привіт наступний
відкриває абзац у цьому абзаці,
починайте ввічливо та скажіть причину
чому ви пишете, ви можете використовувати
фрази як справи. Я не чув від
вас багато років
або дякую за ваш лист, наступна
частина містить основну частину, не забудьте надати
відповіді на всі  пункти завдання
та напишіть ці відповіді в різних
абзацах, ще одну ідею, починайте кожен
абзац з верхнього речення, а потім
надайте більше деталей, що йде до наступного
заключного абзацу, тобто час,
щоб сформулювати все, що ви хотіли б
підкреслити, і закінчити свій лист
ввічливою фразою
прокоментуйте останній підпис,
використовуйте закінчення підпису, наприклад, love
your best wishes і не забудьте використовувати своє
ім'я та отримати,
що це буква, окресліть її структуру,
що ще слід взяти до
уваги, як зв'язати ідеї
в реченні між реченнями або
навіть як зв'язати абзаци, тому ми
говоримо про зв'язування, давайте подивимося
- ідеї посилань у цьому реченні ми повинні
використовувати сполучники в одній із
умов, у яких ви матимете Y, це означає
принаймні тому, що чи ви точно використовуєте
правильно, як зв'язувати  речення або
абзаци, які використовують для початку на
додаток до всього, де використовувати це одна
з умов, які ми мали з множиною,
порада правильно, що є
правильним  місце для використання, по-перше, зробіть це,
по-друге, зробіть щось інше. Ви можете додати
ще кілька фраз-посилань, як ви знаєте,
або насправді отримайте ось ідеї для
зв'язування звуків, наче ваш лист готовий,
принаймні, це чернетка, щоб відредагувати
його, як відредагувати ваш  Я хотів би
поділитися з вами двома потужними джерелами,
перше з яких правильне та покращує зір,
тож давайте подивимося, як це працює,
ви вводите тут свій лист-відповідь, а
потім знову вводите його нижче, ви можете побачити
на зеленому фоні  кількість слів,
а потім подивіться на правий стовпець,
ось відгуки непогано
Еліан, ви можете побачити, що вони виділені
фрази, які слід покращити,
але кількість ваших спроб і навіть
якщо рівні ваші букви b2 c1
непогані для вас  може встановити ваш таймер, щоб перевірити,
скільки часу вам знадобиться кількість
спроб без будь-яких обмежень, тому
практикуйте це та покращуйте своє письмо
щоразу, коли інша служба працює граматично,
коли ви встановлюєте її в будь-який браузер, ви
можете використовувати його для перевірки
Зверніть увагу, що ви пишете, обидва ці
ресурси безкоштовні, вони мають достатньо
варіантів, тому я повністю
впевнений, що ці ресурси стануть
вам у пригоді для перегляду,
тому сьогодні ми вміємо писати
неформальні листи, і так  домашнє завдання -
написати листа-відповідь, використовуючи
підказки, які ми зробили під час уроку, і
покращити його, використовуючи правильні інструменти, і
покращити і граматично наш урок закінчено,
слідкуйте за оновленнями і до скорої зустрічі
[Музика]
ви